the San Diego comic-con was awash with
superhero TV and film reveals so let's
wade through the tides like Aquaman and
go over the biggest DC and Warner
Brothers news from the show Warner
Brothers kick things off with the first
trailer for Wonder Woman the trailer
highlights the relationship between gal
gadot's diana prince and chris pine's
Steve Trevor after the latter washes up
on the shores of their mascara from what
we've seen it seems the film will be set
sometime around 1916 during the height
of World War one directed by Patty
Jenkins who also directed 2008
critically acclaimed monster starring
Charlize Theron Wonder Woman will
release June twenty-first next year DC's
answer to the Avengers the Justice
League got its first trailer and it is a
doozy confirming earlier reports that
the film would be much lighter in tone
than Batman vs Superman the trailer sees
Bruce Wayne recruiting the Warriors he
needs to battle an enemy he believes is
coming there's a better look at jason
momoa as Arthur curry aka Aquaman ray
Fisher's cyborg and Ezra Miller's
wisecracking flash the latter has
probably the best moment of the trailer
when in order to test his reflexes Bruce
Wayne Hills a Batarang at the speedster
Justice League will hit theaters on
november seventeenth 2017 in a little
under two weeks we'll finally get to see
Suicide Squad when it releases on august
five but in the mean time warner
brothers in DC released a final trailer
for the upcoming supervillain movie the
trailer showcases the team's dynamic
opening with will smith's Deadshot
reminding them that they're the patsies
they're too bad guys we then see
snippets of the main members including
Harley Quinn killer croc Captain
Boomerang katana and El Diablo Suicide
Squad follows a gang of super villains
who are coerced into taking dangerous
missions in exchange for reduced
sentences the film has been reported to
potentially take in 140 million dollars
in the US for its opening which would
make it the biggest opening for Will
Smith after 2007 I am Legend rounding
out the superhero reveals this year
Warner Brothers has dropped a trailer
for the lego batman movie reprising his
role as the dark knight from 2014 s the
lego movie will arnett heads up the cast
alongside michael cera as the Boy Wonder
Robin and Zach Galifianakis as the Joker
the film retains the humor and visual
style of the lego movie and will follow
Batman as he attempts to thwart the
Joker's hostile takeover of Gotham City
or coming to terms with the idea that he
may have to drop the whole lone
vigilante thing the lego batman movie is
directed by chris mckay of Robot Chicken
Fame and will release sometime in 2017
moving away from superheroes Warner
Brothers has revealed the first train
for the new king kong film hong Skull
Island starring brie Larson and Tom
Hiddleston the film is described as a
thrilling and original new adventure
that reveals the untold story of how
Kong became king it also apparently
features the biggest Kong ever seen with
the monstrous ape set to measure in at a
staggering 100 feet Kong Skull Island
will form part of an ongoing shared
monster movie universe with 2014 s
Godzilla and the upcoming Godzilla two
and Godzilla verse on you'll be able to
see the spectacle for yourself when Kong
comes to theaters on March 10 next year
guy ritchie of Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels fame is bringing his
signature style to the legend of King
Arthur the film starring sons of
anarchy's Charlie Hunnam as the titular
character will retell the classic
excalibur myth tracing arthur's journey
from the streets to the throne the
trailer shows a film that combines
Richie's down-to-earth underdog heroes
with the grand sweeping medieval worlds
and battles of modern fantasy films King
Arthur legend of the sword will be
released on March 24 2017 finally Warner
Brothers have released another look at
the harry potter spin-off fantastic
beasts and where to find them the film
sees eddie redmayne as newts commander
travelling from England to New York with
a case full of magical beasts
unfortunately they somehow get loose and
it's up to the Hogwarts expertly to
recapture them as his mistake threatens
to ignite already building tensions
between magical and non-magical people
scripted by original writer JK Rowling
fantastic beasts and where to find them
is set for release on November 18 this
year be sure to check out all of our
stories from comic-con on site for a
look at the new characters announced for
injustice to more in-depth character
breakdowns for Suicide Squad and a look
at the new line of DC collectibles and
for everything dark broody and probably
starring the Joker keep your eyes on
gamespot